hey Madison le one of the big surprises
from last weekend's PSX conference was
the announcement of res infinite and I
know you're a big fan of of the original
game what was the thing that most
excited you about this one well just the
idea that a lot of people are gonna be
able to get their hands on this you know
sort of an older game came on the ps2
actually came out drink ass before that
that's right but just sort of having
this sort of weird rhythm music shooter
games we've given the hands of gamers
it's been sort of an iconic one yeah
yeah and I guess the big thing too was
you know the fact that they announced it
for PlayStation VR I mean you can
apparently also play it just as a normal
PlayStation 4 game but I guess the big
hook for PSX was the fact that you can
strap on a PlayStation VR headset and
move around that world is that something
that excites you do you think as a fan
of the original game
given the aesthetic and the visuals of
it yeah definitely
just to have that sort of next level of
immersion within that game in general
will definitely be a crazy step up yeah
you're right the original narrative of
this game was you know you're a hacker
trying to like infiltrate this system
and it just seems to fit really well
within the conceit of the game already I
guess one of the things that the
original creator of the game Tetsuya
Mizuguchi was actually on stage and this
sort of silver glowing suit showing it
off and apparently that thing actually
has sort of like emotion sort of like
vibrators or like all the different
points throw at it as well to try and
sort of recreate some of the sounds and
the sort of impact of the game with you
know the game itself so that well it was
kind of a weird thing I thought right
right and you got to try that out right
yeah I didn't get to fit in the silver
suit itself because you know they told
me that's only for really skinny people
and I'm not really skinny and they
essentially just wrapped around your
arms your chest in your legs and had I
think 26 panels that actually vibrated
depending on what was actually happening
on-screen so I got to do a really really
quick demo of that like it probably took
about ten minutes to get the suit on and
the demo hood so it was something about
- so you know I left that wanting to
experience more you know the the
vibrations on you you know
they'll you know the sand creepers it
felt really good yeah and then I guess
that's the main question people have
with this thing you know like how does
it actually feel but it did feel really
good at thought you know you did feel a
lot more connected to you know the music
within the game and what you were
actually trying to do it was kind of
strange though because we were talking
with the developers afterwards and I was
telling me that you know the the suit
itself and all the different sort of
like pressure points on it actually
vibrated like different strengths so you
know you would have sort of light
touches and more sort of like you know
more hardcore vibrations but in the
short demo I had it was kind of really
hard to discern some of that stuff
because he was so quick I was trying to
get used to the whole sensation of being
you know inflation PlayStation VR and
doing it at the same time right right
but unfortunately apparently it's not
going to be a commercial no no it's not
gonna be a commercial thing I mean the
the the suit that they had on on for
certain journalists at PS X was one that
they developed within in a university in
Japan so this all this stuff is just
prototype so what they're telling us is
they have no real plan plans right now
to actually try and make this a
commercial viable thing but who knows I
think the reaction was you know pretty
positive after was like is it like is
that some sort of suit something you
want to try Matt definitely and I can
imagine it could make room kind of a
crazy weird experience yeah I think
resin VR is still something that I'm
really looking forward to if that motion
suit ever came out I would love to play
it in that but I think resident VR is
something that on its own will be good
enough and right now with darlings like
you know what the release date for this
thing is but you know I think we're all
both in 2016